[Music]
you told NPR that if Serena Williams run
the men's circuit she'd be like number
700 in the world okay it didn't go over
big with my daughter's either okay John
McEnroe addresses his comments about
Serena Williams yet again on Tuesdays
Late Show with Stephen Colbert the
retired tennis pro offered this analogy
did they say that about girl basketball
players that they're as good as Michael
Jordan for example they might say
women's basketball McEnroe also got a
little competitive people always ask me
can you beat Cirelli Serena Williams my
girls don't think I can beat her now I
thought I could beat her she's pregnant
so maybe I should play her now whatever
better a better chance but either way I
wish you the absolute best he's the best
thing that's happened to American tennis
in the last 10-15 years it's not the
first time McEnroe has talked about his
controversial statement he was asked
about it on Tuesdays CBS this morning
would like to apologize no the offer is
this is because it seems in tennis
unlike other sports that they're always
asking about how women they always ask
me how I would do for somebody why is it
this whole bag John McEnroe how would he
do against Serena why don't you combine
just solve the problem I'm sure the men
would be all for this the men and women
play together
[Music]
you